[Musik]
eine 16-jährige jugendliche die sehr
aktiv auch bei social media ist es
kälter tonwerk sind sie eigentlich fan
von ihr
also ich finde er sehr beachtlich wie
man in so einem jungen alter schon auch
dinge von denen man zutiefst überzeugt
ist bewegen kann das für nicht
bemerkenswert
ich glaube dass auch greta thunberg
nicht alleine ist sondern auch sie
braucht als jemand der dinge
voranbringen wir menschen die ihr dabei
helfen und das ist trotzdem
bemerkenswert wie ein mensch es schafft
ebenso viele andere auch mitzuziehen
insofern finde ich das ist eine
beachtliche persönlichkeit hat am
wochenende dieses foto aufsehen gesorgt
da tun wer dem überfüllten ic sitzt da
zwischen koffern so können wir das alle
zumindest aus der studentenzeit oder aus
jungen jahren zwischen zwischen den
koffer sitzend auf dem gang das ist das
bild was vermittelt wird und was sie
gepostet hat er kommt später raus sie
ist erster klasse gereist was hier nicht
vorzuwerfen ist aber was man auf dem
foto einfach nicht sieht finden sie das
glaubwürdig ja also ich das ist
natürlich keine gute situation
ich finde dass er hinter jedem bild
immer auch ein stück die nachricht
hinter der nachricht steckt er und es
ist eben nicht alles so schwarz und weiß
und sowieso wie greta dann doch noch ein
sitzplatz bekommen hat so ist es auch
wenn die regierung ein klima paket
beschließt was vielleicht bei einigen
leuten nicht genug ist oder zu wenig zu
spät
da muss man trotzdem sagen der werden 54
milliarden jetzt ausgegeben durch die
bundesregierung um in klimaschutz machen
das ist eine andere frage ist die
meinten sie ist zum symbol einer ganzen
bewegung geworden und man postet solche
fotos auch in der mit einer gewissen
intention zu sagen ich bin eine von euch
ist wohl die ständig reise auch eben auf
dem gang zwischen den koffern sitzen und
die züge in deutschland sind leider
leider so sehr überfüllt und kommt
später aus der erste klasse und hat den
sitz platz
also ich hätte so verstanden dass sie
die erste strecke keinen sitzplatz hatte
und dann aber 1 hatte sie hat den
zweiten teil der geschichte halt nicht
öffentlich erzählt wahrscheinlich wusste
sie warum
und das sind natürlich dinge klar dass
ist auch ein stück weit selbst
inszenierung und ich weiß jetzt dass
glaubwürdigkeit machen sie zu einem
gewissen teil sie sehen das ja in der
heutigen debatte kostet das
wahrscheinlich schon ein paar
glaubwürdigkeit punkte das kann schon
sein
also ich meine sie hat ja nicht gelogen
wie hatte um sie hat immer nur nicht
alles erzählt ja
[Musik]